Everybody we're back.
Tony V., very funny guy
is gonna be out here in just a second
but first it's time to introduce
a new segment on our show.
We're all very excited about it.
It's the "Late Night Salmon Grab."
♪ Late Night Salmon Grab ♪
(audience cheering)
All right, folks. Here's how it works.
In this tank right here is
a real live Pacific salmon
flown to us at great expense
from the state of Washington.
Now, folks, here's what's gonna happen.
I'm gonna ask for one
volunteer from the audience.
Just a typical random audience member.
(audience laughing)
And that lucky person
is gonna come down here
and see if he or she can grab
the salmon with their teeth.
Now, folks, if that person succeeds,
we have a couple of
great prizes standing by.
It sounds pretty tough.
I mean, to grab a salmon with your teeth,
and, they move fast.
Well Andy, I think someone in the audience
is gonna be up to it, okay?
(audience laughing)
Now Liz, why don't we just
turn the cameras around,
see if we have any volunteers at all,
anybody who's interested in
(audience cheering)
salmon and let's see.
Just a random person in the audience.
That's great, yeah, how about you sir?
[Dale] Me?
[Conan] Right there,
that's terrific, you sir, right there.
[Dale] Excuse me, yay!
Yeah, it's gonna be grand, yeah!
(audience cheering)
What's up man, Dale
Westbrook, what's going on?
No I actually I kinda thought that
Hey, Dale Westbrook, what's happening man,
I'm psyched to be here,
I'm totally ah look at him.
(Dale clapping)
Yeah but I meant to choose
All right, so what do I do?
Just get in there and grab the
salmon with my teeth, right?
Yeah.
Cool.
(Dale whoops)
Do you really, you really,
you really wanna do it? 'Cause I
Dude I love fish, let's get it on!
Yeah!
I'm coming for ya!
(audience laughing)
All right, Max, drum roll please.
(drums rumbling)
All right.
(Dale gurgles)
(Dale roars)
(Conan yells)
Yeah!
(triumphant music)
(audience cheering)
That was
Wow
All right
That was
What do I win?
Well what'd you win okay,
well we had two prizes lined up for you.
Okay.
You know but I don't
(audience laughing)
I don't I don't think
you're gonna like them so
What are you talking about,
anything's cool, I'll take it.
All right, well your your first prize
is an actual live bee hive.
Giving him a bee hive, everybody.
A bee hive?
Oh, yeah! Check it out!
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
(Dale laughing)
Ow, ow, oh, oh, ow.
(audience laughing)
You're all right, huh? You're okay?
Yeah, ow.
Okay, all right.
What's my next prize?
I don't think it's such a good idea,
why don't we'll just
stick with that prize.
What're you talking about,
I loved the beehive.
(audience laughing)
I think ya gotta do it,
I mean, what the hell?
All right, all right.
[Dale] Two prizes.
All right, your other prize is a date
with the sexiest gal in town.
I'm talking of course
about none other than
Griselda Grizzly!
Big date with the
(audience cheering)
Wow.
I've always wanted to
have sex with a bear!
Yeah!
(Dale grunting)
This is great!
All right, we're gonna
take a little break.
Maybe we'll try this again
sometime, a different way.
Tony V's coming up, stick
around, we'll be right